los estudiantes están hablando de
matemáticas hablan en los pasillos y en
el patio y quieren ir a casa y
conectarse a khan academy es muy
emocionante
ah
[Música]
la pregunta que constantemente tienen
que responder los distritos de nivel
alto es porque cambiar si las cosas van
bien y al final se redujo a lo que es
nuestra misión y nuestra visión cómo
podemos hacer que el aprendizaje sea
significativo para cada alumno a nivel
individual
al evaluar khan academy o cualquier otra
herramienta todo se reduce al beneficio
para el alumno y el beneficio para el
maestro en ese orden
khan academy les da a los alumnos las
instrucciones el aprendizaje que
necesitan al nivel donde se encuentran
en el tiempo en que lo necesitan el
valor para el maestro es la información
disponible el maestro puede saber en
cualquier momento en tiempo real donde
un alumno está avanzando exitosamente o
donde está batallando los beneficios le
permiten a los maestros repensar su
tiempo en clase o incluso tener más
tiempo no pierden tiempo en habilidades
que los alumnos ya dominan
pueden ajustar su tiempo mejor para
satisfacer las necesidades de los
alumnos así que empezamos con tres
maestros como 120 alumnos y ahora en el
segundo año ya tenemos más de 1000
alumnos usando khan academy como
herramienta en línea y cerca de 50
maestros en el proyecto
[Música]
desde la primera vez que lo usamos los
chicos quedaron fascinados no podían
dejar de hablar de esto estaban
emocionados yo podía ver el entusiasmo
que querían pasar horas y horas haciendo
cálculos matemáticos así que ya desde
ahí era un gran lujo porque los chicos
no muy a menudo quieren sentarse a hacer
cálculos matemáticos podemos avanzar más
rápido en el plan de estudios así que
tenemos más tiempo para organizar
proyectos y otro tipo de actividades que
no son simplemente del libro de texto lo
cual es fantástico porque ahí es donde
realmente aprenden y eso es lo que más
les gusta les emociona trabajar en algo
y ver cómo se aplica en su mundo
pero no podíamos haberlo hecho yo creo
sí de haber introducido khan academy en
nuestras clases
siempre quise hacer cosas nuevas
organizar proyectos nuevos siempre trato
de encontrar la manera de dirigirme a
todos los alumnos de su propio nivel y
siempre tuve la sensación de que no era
muy buena en ello así que cuando llego
khan academy en dos semanas pude ver que
chicos estaban batallando y cuales
estaban pasando un módulo tras otro
empezando con álgebra y con cosas que no
había visto con ellos todavía solo lo vi
y dije esto es increíble
pude organizar grupos pequeños para
ayudarlos a soltarse ver qué nivel
tenían muy por debajo de lo que era el
quinto grado en ese entonces y
finalmente me dio la libertad de saber
que les estaba enseñando a todos y que
ninguno se aburría ayuda porque ahora
puedo localizar ciertas áreas a veces
pueden pasar semanas completas sin saber
que algún alumno no comprendió algo dos
capítulos atrás pero con khan academy
eso sale a la luz más seguido puedes
corregirlo y salvar el día
cada academia ha impactado notablemente
a la mayoría de mis alumnos hay quienes
buscan alcanzar metas altas que lo usan
para avanzar les atraen las matemáticas
y quieren explorar nuevas cosas y tienen
la habilidad para hacerlo también hay
alumnos que les cuesta trabajo que
todavía batallan con matemáticas
elementales que no han dominado los
conceptos de 3º o 4º grado y esto les
permite regresar a ellos y llenar esos
vacíos para que tengan unas bases
sólidas estos alumnos se apropian de su
aprendizaje aplican su conocimiento de
matemáticas a diversas situaciones y
tienen oportunidad de interactuar
individualmente conmigo o en grupos
pequeños en donde hablamos de
matemáticas de forma que realmente
contribuye a su aprendizaje antes perdía
mucho tiempo recogiendo las tareas
revisando las cargando una mochila
enorme llena de material a la escuela y
de regreso y cortando me con el papel y
ahora tengo toda la información en mi
computadora
es muy útil porque puedo verlo a las 10
de la noche a las 5 de la mañana oa las
3 de la tarde oa la mitad de mi clase y
tengo todo ahí he recibido correos de
padres que dicen tenemos problemas con
la tarea y yo puedo revisar y ver lo que
ese chico está haciendo de esa misma
noche y encontrar el ejercicio
específico que le está causando
problemas y así planear mi clase para el
día siguiente con este alumno mi
enseñanza es más informada más
focalizada y ya no tengo que cargar esa
mochila enorme
[Música]
lo más emocionante para mí ha sido
simplemente la idea de que ahora la
puerta está abierta a otras
posibilidades porque las herramientas
cambian pero el objetivo es el mismo al
optimizar el tiempo de aprendizaje que
tenemos con los alumnos los maestros de
este distrito han tomado una serie de
cursos este año sobre el aprendizaje
combinado y cómo incrementar khan
academy y estamos viendo nuevas
prácticas de los maestros que son
increíbles y están haciendo cosas
geniales con khan academy y otras
herramientas para niños las clases de
matemáticas se han vuelto más ricas e
interesantes para los alumnos
inevitablemente estoy aprendiendo junto
con los alumnos y a veces es muy
incómodo pero a fin de cuentas creo que
es una experiencia muy poderosa porque
los alumnos pueden ver en acción como
alguien puede estar aprendiendo toda la
vida como maestra eso es lo que busco
enseñarles a los alumnos que no se trata
sólo de aprender matemáticas odio
ciencias está semana
no de aprender durante toda tu vida
date permiso de no ser el experto por un
rato y de aprender junto con ellos y eso
va a formar una relación increíble entre
tus alumnos y tú mientras juntos
descubren cosas y juntos celebran sus
logros
[Música]